willie peralta will get the ball here to
start game two of this uh double header
and uh he's making a second start the
payoff
a chopper to short zach short throws on
the run and gets him
[Applause]
there's a drive to right field no mar
mazzara drifts back and he's got it for
out number two now the payoff
easy hop for zach short
houston went one two three just twice in
game one already they go one two three
against willie peralta bottom of the
first inning lance mccullers junior
ready to go facing the tigers for the
second time this season
over to center for a base hit for
jonathan scope now the 3-1
and he laid off it for a free pass now
he's on two on cabrera with two on and
one out
and a swing and a miss
pal tip caught by maldonado first
strikeout for lance big pitch
two away for nomar mazzara
on the ground
scope will score grossman all the way to
third and nomar mazzara gives the tigers
the early lead
see how he pulls his hands in there to
get the barrel to the ball good focus
kept his head down hit the ball up the
middle
no problem at all for jonathan scope to
come around third and score one nothing
tigers go to the top of the second
inning
good stop by haas alvarez goes down to
second and they got him
that is great hustle right there
by eric haws i think alvarez assumed
that there's no way he's going to even
throw the ball the ball gets away from
eric haas quite a ways all the way off
the dirt to his left onto the grass look
at this the hustle and then the accurate
throw again
he initially missed the tag
but alvarez slid over the bag came off
the bag and that's when willie applied
the tag kept it on him
3-2
he pops it up
haas out peralta takes control there you
go jack love it the pitcher won't love
it now the pitcher got it
big smile on his face bottom of the
second willy castro
harold castro and zach short for the
tigers
lance is a pretty good fielder doesn't
get as much recognition as that grinky
for his fielding but he makes that play
swing and a miss got him on an elevated
fastball and mccullers caps off a 1-2-3
inning with his second strikeout big
moment here in the ball game in the
third kyle funkhouser is on to try and
get out jose altuve in a one-nothing
tigers lead and the tying run at second
base
outside ball four so it's a walk puts
runners on first and second the astros
have three walks in this game no hits
with brantley coming to the plate
on the ground to second base
a job well done
by kyle funkhouser ready to go in the
fourth inning of this seven inning
contest astros losing the first game of
this double header in seven innings
three to one and julie guriel taps one
slowly towards the third
wild throw by funkhouser didn't have
much of a chance on that play julie
guriel will reach on an infield hit that
broke up the no hitter dan
the 1-0 back up the middle step on the
bag he will and zach short completes the
double play
taylor made just the way we drew it up
miguel cabrera leads things off for
detroit here in the bottom of the fourth
inning tigers lead one-nothing
3-2 swing by cabrera who pounds the
barrel of his bat on the way back to the
dugout as he strikes out for the second
time against mccullers
three two pitch is sent in the air to
right field kyle tucker waits for it
puts it away for the final out of the
inning lance mccullers has retired 10
straight one up the game al funkhouser
faces the six seven eight hitters here
in the fifth inning the o2 swinging a
miss he got him in the fastball away
boy he was absolutely tardy also i mean
tardy
and he strikes out toro back-to-back
punch-outs here in the fifth for kyle
funkhouser see the spike velocity right
there 97 miles an hour up in the zone
straw takes off one two swing and a miss
he got him with a sharp slider down on
the way what a job by kyle funkhouser he
strikes out the side in the fifth here's
harold castro flew out to left back in
the second
little looper to center
and harold castro has the tigers third
hit of the day it's kind of like
jonathan scope only not even as hard as
that
he lifts a high fastball got jammed off
the label of the bat but it gets over
toro's head see if zach short can keep
things rolling here there's a strikeout
short goes down for the second time in
this game six strikeouts for lance
mccullers jr
two away in the fifth
ambadu draws a walk a couple men aboard
now two away here on the tigers fifth
for jonathan scope
through the left side for a base hit
harold castro is going to try and score
the throw
not in time
jonathan scope comes through again and
it's two nothing tigers
a hanging slider right there jonathan
skope pulled it through the left side
hole to the left of toro he go for it
and then michael bradley gets a quick
and throws a strike to home plate
but harold just sneaks in there with his
left hand they turn it over to michael
fulmer but he's got a big task to get
out the top of the order here
there's a line drive base hit down the
left field line jose altuve heading to
second base he'll get there with a
double astros get their second base
runner to second base in the game a lead
off double for out two bay and now
giordano alvarez he's walked and
grounded into a double play
three two pitch hit high deep to center
field all the way back is badou near the
wall he will jump oh
we're tied up at two
the big man ties it up on home run
number 13 of the year
outstanding man did we need that here's
correa oh for two and this road trip
carlos correa gives the astros a lead
a laser beam to the left
correa follows yorn on and the astros
lead 3-2 on correa's 15th home run of
the year
he's not afraid i told you he hit some
big home runs he does yes he has ryan
presley comes on to try and close things
out in the bottom half of the seventh
inning
swaying and a miss
presley gets harold castro on strikes
that's the curveball froze him on the
curveball dropped it in on the corner
for a called third strike two strikeouts
for ryan presley and the astros need one
more to finish off this game
there it
is strike ball game over astros win it
three to two they split the double
header
after losing the opener 3-1 they come
back baggy with a big rally in the sixth
inning to take the night cap great win
that's what great teams do